mehr als sechs monate krieg in der
ukraine und tag 4 der ukrainischen gegen
offensive im süden des landes wir wollen
uns die situation auf der karte ansehen
seit einigen tagen beziehungsweise seit
montag versucht die ukrainische armee
hier in die region carson vorzudringen
und sie versucht das hier nördlich dass
mehrere flusses der eben die gesamte
provinz gascogne in der mitte
durchschneidet an drei stellen versucht
sie es einmal hier direkt auf carson
einmal hier über den fluss in metz und
einmal hier nördlich aus der region
krimi und wir haben aus verschiedenen
quellen sowohl russland als auch
ukrainischen gehört dass diese offensive
nur extrem zäh voran geht das ist hier
viele viele opfer gegeben hat sowohl auf
ukrainischer als auch auf russischer
seite manche sagen bis zu 1200 opfer in
nur einigen tagen und dass die situation
extrem schwierig das für beide seiten
wir haben aber neue videos die uns etwas
darüber verraten wie die ukraine
versucht diese offensive voranzutreiben
hier ein video das ja sehr interessant
ist weil es uns zeigt eben wie dieser
vormarsch funktionieren soll wir haben
hier vorne ein aus den niederlanden
gespendetes gepanzertes fahrzeug und
dahinter sehen wir wie wirklich in einer
reihe sich die ukrainische soldaten hier
dahinter verstecken und darauf warten
dass ihr weiter vordringen können aber
sie haben nicht selbst die kraft hier
voranzukommen sondern sie brauchen hier
links diesen panzer der eben über diesen
berg sich rüber wagt und eben einen
schuss abgibt auf die gegner die davor
sind wir sehen die ukrainische soldaten
können sie gar nicht viel machen die
infanterie muss warten bis die panzer
sozusagen den weg freischießen auf der
anderen seite ist es extrem wichtig dass
sie da sind weil nur weil sie da sind
kann dieser panzer der jetzt gleich
schießt nicht beispielsweise von der
seite attackiert werden es ist also für
die russen unmöglich hier eine
zangenbewegung auszuführen und den
panzer anzugreifen also diese diese
zusammenarbeit von infanterie
gepanzerten fahrzeugen und eben panzern
das ist etwas was ja die russische seite
fast gar nicht kann die kann entweder
über panzer oder infanterie was die
ukraine aber versuchen hier fortzuführen
ein weiteres video zeigt uns von
ukrainischen soldaten die gerade warten
die da hinten hier sehen wie etwas hoch
schießt und das ist die heimat das ist
also diese amerikanische raketensystem
was hier eingesetzt wird und das neue
ist dass es seit einigen tagen nicht
mehr nur hinter der front eingesetzt
wird um munitionslager beispielsweise zu
zerstören sondern dass die russen sagen
seit einige tage seit beginn dieser
offensive werden auch unsere front
position mitte heimers angegriffen und
das ist eben sehr interessant diese
extrem starke und extrem
leistungsfähige raketen artillerie wird
seit einigen tagen von der ukraine
eingesetzt um direkt an der front hier
auch die russen zu schlagen letztes
video eine kleine erfolgsmeldung in
diesem jahr in dieser wir sehr zählen
offensive wir sehen hier einen
ukrainische soldaten und auf den kommt
ein bnp zwei schützenpanzer zu der kommt
sehr schnell angefahren und das ganze
hat einen grund als allererstes sehen
wir jetzt vielleicht mal dass er dieses
z überall drauf hat dh dass z wir sehen
das hier einmal hier ist das zelt zu
sehen und ermorden dass das zelt zu
sehen das ist ja eigentlich die
markierung der russischen
invasionstruppen aber wir lassen das
video mal weiter laufen und wir sehen
warum dieser ugandische soldaten nicht
fürchtet nämlich hier oben wird die
ukrainische flagge gehisst dieser dmp
zwei schützenpanzer wurde also von den
ukrainern erbeutet während dieser
offensive und die feiern jetzt dass sie
hier zumindest einen schützenpanzer den
russen abgenommen haben wir müssen aber
auch noch in den osten gucken zu guter
letzt oder leider nicht zu guter letzt
hier gerät die russische offensive
weiter sowohl bei der stadt donetzk
wurde auch vor ort piske jetzt komplett
eingenommen wurde oder zumindest wo alle
ukrainischen truppen vertrieben wurde
aus diesem vor ort der strategisch sehr
wichtig ist weil er eben der erste vor
ort ist hier neben dem netz der noch vor
kurzem und 2014 von der ukraine gehalten
wurde und wir haben auch im bach mit
weiteren offensiven und wir sehen uns
mal an wie die russen hier versuchen
vorzubringen nämlich ganz ähnlich wie
die ukraine wo anders aber eben auch mit
einem unterschied wir sehen hier diese
panzer offensive das heißt wir haben
verschiedene panzer ein die miteinander
vordringen handelt sich um uralte 62
panzer und wir sehen es ist keine
infanterie die nehmen ja die panzer
dringen als panzer vor die infanterie
sitz drauf und wir sehen vielleicht auch
diese käfige da oben die wir immer sehen
manche sind nennen sie so genannte cold
cases also käfige die so ein bisschen
die verzweiflung wegdrücken sollen hier
sehen wir ihnen ganz gut hinten der
panzer und da oben drauf dieser käfig
und die russen benutzen diesen käfig aus
zwei gründen zum einen glauben sie dass
irgendwie er sie gegen die a villen
raketen schützt diese raketen der
amerikaner die immer wieder eingesetzt
werden zum anderen ist es aber auch so
dass die ukraine bereits seit einigen
monaten diese kleinen drohen anwenden
mit denen sie von oben in den panzer
eine granate einfallen lassen und
selbstverständlich wenn darüber ein dach
ist kann zumindest die lupe die öffnung
des panzers dort oben nicht getroffen
werden dass das also ein grund also zwei
gründe warum die russen hier diese
käfige einsätzen auf jedem ihrer panzer
darauf diesen käfig haben um sich eben
irgendwie gegen ukrainische
drohnenangriffe und ja wenn raketen
angriffe zu schützen entscheidend aber
auch die russen können sich weiter mit
panzer verbänden vorwärts bewegen auch
die russen sind weiter offen in der
offensive eben nicht im süden des landes
sondern im osten aber dort machen sie
auch heute weitere geländegewinne
[Musik]